.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THEY SAID WE ARE IN OVERTIME.
THAT MEANS WE'VE GOT A RUNOFF.
I OUGHT TO BE UP FOR THIS.
>> GEORGIA IS THE THIRD STATE
THAT COULD DIFFER OUTSIDE THE
STATE OF THE SENATE AND WITH
THAT SECOND RUNOFF ELECTION IN
AS MANY YEARS IT'S THE SECOND
MOST EXPENSIVE RACE THIS CYCLE
TOTALING $262 MILLION THUS FAR.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE REPUBLICA
HERSCHEL WALKER WHO IS REALLY
GOOD IN OVERTIME I HAVE TO SAY.
GEORGIA SENATE CANDIDATE
HERSCHEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT AS ALWAYS.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING RIGHT NOW
AFTER THIS WILD WEEK WHERE WE
HAVE SO MANY RACES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY STILL UNDECIDED AND YOU
ARE HEADING INTO THIS RUNOFF?
>> I FEEL PRETTY GOOD.
THE REASON WHY I'M STILL
FIGHTING FOR THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
THAT'S WHAT I GOT IN.
I FELT LIKE THE PEOPLE IN WASH
GEORGIA WEREN'T REPRESENTING AS
WELL.
GEORGIA NEEDED A CHAMPION AND I
AM THAT CHAMPION BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO GET INTO WASHINGTON AN
LET THE BOAT PEOPLE'S VOICES BE
HEARD AND LET THE PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A CHANCE BECAUSE
SENATOR WARNOCK HAS NOT DONE IT
SINCE HE WENT TO WASHINGTON.
>> MITCH McCONNELL IS TURNING
TO GOVERNOR CAMP FOR HELP AND
THIS RACE, POLITICO IS REPORTIN
THAT KEMP IS LOANING HIS GET OU
THE VOTE MACHINE TO THE SENATE'
GOP VOTER TURNOUT FRED GIVING
THEM ENTRÉE TO A POLITICAL TEAM
INCREASINGLY VIEWED AS ONE OF
THE GOP'S MOST FORMIDABLE STATE
OPERATIONS AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE UNDERSTAND THE DEMOCRATS HAV
INVESTED $7 MILLION AND GET OUT
THE VOTE EFFORTS, WHICH SOUNDS
LIKE VALID HARVESTING TO ME
WHICH IS LEGAL IN YOUR STATE.
WHAT IS THE WAY TO WIN THIS RAC
NOW WITH THE REMAINING WEEKS
THAT YOU HAVE?
>> IT IS SUCH A SHORT TIME AND
THE DEMOCRATS IS TRYING TO BUY
THE SEATS SEAT.
SO THAT'S WHAT ENCOURAGED
EVERYONE TO GO TO TEAM HERSCHEL
.COM.
CONTRIBUTE TO MY CAMPAIGN, BUT
THINK GOVERNOR KEMP RATE STACEY
ABRAMS HAD A GOOD MACHINE OUT
ALSO, BUT GOVERNOR KEMP HAS
PROVEN THAT HE CAN BEAT THAT
MACHINE.
YOU BEAT THAT MACHINE BY GETTIN
PEOPLE TO OUT GET OUT AND KNOCK
ON THE DOORS AND DOING THE WORK.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THE WORK AND
LETTING THE VOTERS NO EYES TO
AND WITH YOU GUYS, I WILL I
STEAMER GEORGIA AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO STAND WITH GEORGIA.
WHAT RIGHT I WANT TO DO I WANT
EVERY KID IN THE U.S. TO HAVE
THAT AMERICAN DREAM THAT I'VE
HAD.
IF SENATOR WARNOCK GETS ELECTED
BACK TO THE SENATE, THEY WANT T
HAVE THAT CHANCE TO HAVE THAT
DREAM.
LIKE I SAID, NOT ON MY WATCH.
I HAVE BEEN BLESSED AND I WANT
EVERYONE ELSE TO HAVE THOSE
BLESSINGS AS WELL.
>> HERSCHEL, I WAS TALKING TO A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO USED TO LIVE
IN GEORGIA AND HE SAID THE WAY
TO GUARANTEE HERSCHEL'S WIN IS
NOT ABOUT MONEY, IT'S ABOUT
UNITY.
REPUBLICAN UNITY.
WOULD IT BE NOT IDEAL FOR YOU,
AND FOR YOUR RUNOFF CHANCES TO
HAVE DONALD TRUMP ONSTAGE RON
DESANTIS AND GOVERNOR KEMP AND
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS A PROBLEM
PROMINENT REPUBLICAN
CONSERVATIVE ALTOGETHER PUTTING
ALL THEIR DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND
URGING THE VOTERS TO GET OUT TO
SAVE THE SENATE FOR REPUBLICANS.
WOULDN'T THAT BE IDEAL?
>> THAT WOULD BE TOTALLY IDEAL
PERIODS AND I WOULD LOVE IT
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT EGO FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
I SAID I WANT TO BRING UNITY TO
THIS COUNTRY.
RIGHT NOW THE PERSON I AM
RUNNING AGAIN, THE LEFT WANTED
TO BUY.
IN MY RIGHT BIBLE I SAID HOUSE
DIVIDED CANNOT STAND.
RIGHT NOW THIS COUNTRY IS
SEPARATED, WE ARE SEPARATED
BECAUSE OUR PRESIDENT WANTS TO
DIVIDE US.
SENATOR WARNOCK WANTS TO PER TH
PROBLEM WITH AMERICA IS RACISM.
WE HAVE PROBLEMS HERE, BUT WE
ARE STILL THE GREATEST COUNTRY
AND THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T SEE PEOPLE TRYING TO
CROSS THE BORDER TO GET INTO
CHINA OR INTO RUSSIA.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET INTO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BECAUS
WE GOT THE GREATEST THING RIGHT
HERE.
>> THE BIG LINE OUT OF THE MEDI
THIS WEEK HAS BEEN MAGA LIKE
POPULIST CONSERVATISM IS EXTREME
.
WHAT DO YOU SAY AND REACTION TO
THAT, THAT IS THE MANTRA OF THE
LEFT, THEY THINK IT WORKS FOR
THEM SO THEY ARE GOING TO.
AMERICA FIRST IS NOT EXTREME.
>> LET ME SAY THIS YEAR.
IF YOU LIVE IN AMERICA,
SHOULDN'T YOU WANT AMERICA TO B
GREAT AGAIN?
I WILL NEVER ANNOUNCE I WANT
CHINA TO BE GREAT AGAIN WHILE
I'M LIVING IN AMERICA.
RIGHT NOW THE PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON HAVE PUT A SECOND
PAIR THEY WANTED, BUT YET WE
HAVE COME SO FAR.
WE HAVE COME SO FAR AND I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE US BACK.
I WILL SAY THIS HERE, THE GREEN
AGENDA, WE ARE PREPARED FOR I
WILL BE THE FIRST ONE TO RAISE
MY HAND.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE NOT READY.
WE WOULD PUT OUR SELF WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY PROBLEM
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT KID.
WE'RE GIVING THE ENERGY TO OUR
ENEMY.
WORK CREATING A NATIONAL
SECURITY PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT LEADERS ANYWHERE IN
WASHINGTON.
WHEN THE UNITED STATES LEADS,
THE WHOLE WORLD DOES WELL, BUT
RIGHT NOW WE ARE NOT THE LEADER
AND THE PEOPLE OF RUSSIA SEEM T
BE OKAY WITH IT.
I WANT EVERYBODY OUT THERE TO
KNOW THIS IS NOT THE NEW NORM.